there's like uh there's like a nice
little head rush sometimes when you get
that heart fading
that's uh that's enjoyable
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we close out
another year of the show with daniel
radcliffe
he's of course known the world over for
his role as harry potter in the eight
film series as well as his work on
broadway tv and film
you can catch his latest projects escape
from pretoria
and the kimmy schmidt interactive
special which are both streaming on
netflix now
daniel radcliffe welcome to the show
hello thank you so much for having me
um this is both exciting and terrifying
let me try to calm you down just a
little bit
how are you with spicy food like is it
something that you reach for do you
reach for the hot sauce i mean i
i think i do um but i'm now realizing
that like and having watched the show
and become
aware of the scoville scale as a thing i
realized that i don't know
uh where anything that i've ever eaten
pranks on that scale so i think of
myself as being someone who likes hot
sauce and spicy foods but everything
i've ever had might be like at this end
over here
and and today i will experience what the
other end is like
so we'll see
so long since i've been this like
legitimately nervous for energy
it's a really cool thing
yeah that's crime
[Music]
so i want to start by talking about your
latest film escape from pretoria which
tells the real-life story of three
political prisoners
escaping a prison in south africa in the
late 1970s
and it really is such a unique and
daring escape
when you think about your real life
conversations with the actual tim jenkin
what stands out to you when you think
about what he says and how it all
actually worked out the amazing thing
about tim so for anyone that doesn't
know like a little bit about the story
um
basically what one of the reasons i was
so into
this film and the script was that it
just seemed like it was a true story and
it was the true story of
one of the most sort of unimaginably
brilliant
escapes that i ever thought of and i was
like how is this not
more widely known about tim jenkin the
guy i play
worked out that the locks were like big
enough
if i can gather enough like wood from
the workshop
i can just like make a key that fits out
of wood
it's a very very cool story how many
takes
did it take you to unlock the door from
inside of your cell using a broomstick
attached to a key
so many and i'm glad you asked that
question because this did not
i mean i i will this is like i'm not
generally a person who's who is given to
bragging or talking myself but i will
say i was the only one of us that
managed to
actually do it um it was definitely like
getting to the point where i was like i
can do it i can do it and the director
was like no we can fake it in editing
it's really okay and i was like no no
please wait give me one more try and i
was like yeah but we really want lunch
like can we please stop doing this
and uh eventually like i i got i got one
complete take which which did make it
into the film i was
honestly it's like my best work in the
film at the moment i'm proudest of
[Music]
great very happy with it this is all
that
holding on to this feeling of enjoying
them
there we go so one of the most
underrated british exports are its tv
quiz show and panel games which often
times spawn
popular remakes all over the world as a
trivia head yourself
how do you explain britain's obsession
with the quiz show format
so okay first of all british quiz shows
on the bbc
are my favorite because they because
it's a government-funded like thing
they can't be seen to be like too crazy
with giving away
money so like people really aren't just
doing it for the love of the quizzes
it's one of the holes in my cultural
life in america now i definitely do
miss um and that's why like i have to
say you know jeopardy has really filled
that void so
very sad about the alex trebek news as
the world rightly was
yeah let's talk about jeopardy for a
second because i know that that's a show
that you've made a habit of recording
whenever you're in the states
did you see in 2014 they had an entire
category dedicated to daniel radcliffe
i know no that was yeah that was my my
attention was drawn to that that was a
crazily cool moment the moment i see a
question about myself
on a quiz show and i don't get excited
is the moment i know i've kind of died a
little bit inside
um because there is just like some weird
like hey that's me that's so
crazy like um thing that happens that is
uh
yeah that i i was yeah i was very i was
thrilled by that
and then of course we have to talk about
alex trebek it's been
so great to see all these moving
tributes to a guy who just seems like
he was a part of our lives for decades
what in your opinion
is the magic of trebek as a host in that
quiz show format
i think it's that he um he
you could really tell how much he like
loved the competition and the game of it
um and like you know you would see him
get like
slightly not annoyed but like when you
didn't like when when somebody didn't
clear a board and when there were still
a few questions left or when like
nobody ended up with much money because
nobody done really well he'd just be
like
okay well you know we'll come back for
double jeopardy after breaking i'm sure
we'll all do better then
you could tell that he loved seeing
people that were really smart do
well and that is the essential joy of a
quiz show
and to be the only person that's ever
hosted that i mean
i i'm sure they'll find someone you know
incredible for that job
my god they have gigantic shoes to film
wait this is where dj khaled stopped
each season we put out different sauces
but yeah
the equivalent to the third okay no this
is okay i'm still i'm
i'm still so you've likely spent
thousands of hours of your life fielding
harry potter questions so i apologize
before we get going but you know the
audience they would revolt if we didn't
take a wing to discuss your role
in one of the top grossing film
franchises of all time
can you give me one highlight and one
low light when it comes to the
food that you had to eat and the world
of harry potter
yeah definitely the crazy like banquet
scenes at hogwarts where there was all
like
you know the uh the breakfasts
particularly where it was like i was
just a
11 12 year old child just piling on
fried eggs and bacon and sausages and
baked beans every morning for just
days um that was great and then
in one of the films i have to eat um
ghillie weed
that i think was like black licorice
lace was designed you know it was
designed to look like a kind of
underwater seaweed plant
um that i could then like shovel down my
throat and that was
that was pretty gross i remember by like
the third or fourth day that i was like
oh i
how many more of these are we gonna do i
read that you
wore out something like 60 or 70 wands
and went through 160 pairs of glasses
are those reports exaggerated or does
that sound accurate to you
they are i would definitely say they are
exaggerated the glasses one
massively so like i definitely didn't
break
the glasses that often at all i don't
think
the ones i definitely like broke a lot
because i would just like drum on my
legs with it all the time
and uh do that incessantly and so
probably like once every like
three or four weeks it would just like
weaken to the point where it snapped and
then
i would say i was very sorry to the prop
master and he would give me a look like
please stop drumming they uh yeah they
were very very sweet with us
and uh tolerated more than i hoped they
would from an adult actor
i've heard that that scene in professor
mcgonagall's classroom
had something like 60 animals on the
same set
is that true and if so what do you
remember about that day
oh debating whether it's enough i mean
that i have to tell the story you've
asked about like
such a specific thing in that mcgonagall
i definitely remember that there was a
there were a lot of animals um first of
all to address that part of the question
they must have had upwards of 60 there i
don't imagine they were often
all on set together um but definitely
in that scene uh in the in the
transfiguration classroom
there was a a monkey of some kind
in a in a cage that did just start
jerking off
uh relentlessly but generally speaking
the animals are very well behaved
although i think
i think rupert maybe got peed on by a
bat at one point as well
um but yeah i got away pretty cleanly
after that
that's very nice so in addition to your
tv and film resume you've also taken
your talents to the stage even receiving
a stare and drama desk award nominations
for your work and how to succeed in
business and equus respectively
which is a tougher crowd to please movie
critics or theater buffs
i mean i think there is like
there used to be more of a divide about
like actors who do film coming to stage
and you used to get
i think theater critics that would just
inherently kind of not
like actors if they had been mostly from
movies or like they were coming at it
but i think that isn't really a thing
anymore either like i
definitely am not somebody who like has
particularly suffered from that
i can't split them i think if you do
something shitty everyone's hard to
please
and then hopefully if you do something
good then the people that it's for will
will like it
[Music]
i'm feeling confident i'm gonna have
more on the other side
okay now fine folk
all right daniel we have a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
gram where we do a deep dive on our
guest instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context
but you daniel you've thrown us for a
loop because you have no social media
whatsoever to speak of and it's probably
for the best but
why have you decided to stay off the
apps i would love to say there's some
incredibly thought out
intellectual reason for this because i
considered getting a twitter at one
point
and i 100 know that if i did
you would all be waking up to stories of
like downright gets into fight with
random person on twitter like
when i was younger not anymore thank god
i used to like
look up comments about myself on the
internet and would like read [ __ ] like
that
that is an insane and bad thing to do
and to me like twitter
and and everything just sort of feels
like an extension of that and like
if you have to like if unless i was like
gonna go on and just like read nice
things about myself which also feels
like another kind of unhealthy thing to
do
other than that i just i don't honestly
think i'm like mentally strong enough
but um but right now i'm kind of i'm
kind of all right with that
on the topic of just sort of uh
protecting your privacy you know often
on the show we'll talk about
paparazzi evasion tactics that some of
our guests have used over the years
and you have one that is brilliant it's
one that we've talked about internally
for a long time where you wore the same
leather jacket in public for six months
straight
as a way to like frustrate photographers
where did that idea come from was that
your idea or did somebody feed that to
you no
it was it just happened it was when i
was doing equus in london
and basically like you know there's
you're in a situation where
the paparazzi know where you are and no
you will be leaving at around the same
time every night so
if they just want to like get pictures
of you looking tired and pale which is
my you know my my go-to look um
then you know they can just wait by the
sideway where you come out and
uh and take them as you as you leave
because it's the same door it's the same
background i'm walking out
the same way every night and if i'm
wearing the same clothes they all look
like they're from the same day
so you there's no more value in it um
and so we just i was like great i am
totally comfortable wearing the same
pair of jeans in this jacket for the
next like three months and i
can do that so i did that and then i
also i have to say i
i got given a gift once which is it's
crazy that someone
makes this because it's such a niche
market but it was
given to me as like this is an
anti-paparazzi jacket
and it is uh it's one of those jackets
where it only works at night i think but
if you wear it with the hood up and it's
at night and you take a photo with a
flash
it wipes out everything in the on the
camera except for the hoodie
so like you just get a photo of like a
floating ghost hoodie
um and i have used that once and i never
saw those pictures so i can only assume
it worked
[Music]
wait for the other food to drop that's
very good
i like that a lot this is fine oh god
okay
what are these last four gonna be like
pretty crazy strength to strength to
strength to strength to close it out
so camera guy bill over here is a big
time a24 head and actually put me on to
swiss
army man a while ago you play a farting
corpse
what was the most difficult thing to
shoot between
you know propelling yourself through
water with your own gas
shooting acorns out of your mouth the
water spout the the you know chopping
things with your arm like it's an
axe what was on a behind the scenes
level the most difficult to shoot
water spout was quite tricky i think but
again it was practical which was awesome
so they
fed it up my shirt and like had it come
out of one side
um but that that was kind of tricky but
i think actually the most
like the i mean it was probably the most
challenging to film but also
definitely the mo one of the most fun
things i have ever done
was the opening sequence where he uses
me like a jet ski to escape from that
island
it's the best opening sequence of
any film i have ever done with no
question marks in in my mind
every day on that film you came in and
were like what insane thing are we gonna
do today and how we're gonna do it
because it's not like
they had a ton of money to achieve that
stuff like this was a low budget film
and it does not
look like it for one moment in my
opinion because they just uh
yeah they're geniuses
[Music]
i know things are gonna start getting
bad next because next is the one that
everyone okay
i'm getting real
[Music]
that's nice though there's still like
nice flavors i thought like
so i stuck to my mouth um i thought
there were going to be more
that was just like hot with nothing else
and so far so far this
there's some redeeming quality yes yeah
exactly there's something else going on
and it's nice what is in this one and
i'll say this daniel i know that you
were nervous
before the shoot but i will say this
amongst your countrymen amongst the
fellow brits you are
at the close to the top already oh great
okay good
that that i mean you're saying like for
an english person you can take your
spice which is uh
a backhand sort of yeah but a backhanded
compliment but i'll take it
so as someone who seems drawn to more
esoteric roles i find your love of b
movies really fascinating in fact you
said in a 2014
interview i suppose culturally i'm not
very cultured
what in your opinion is the best dwayne
johnson film
san andreas san andreas is not like
is i like the family storyline in san
andreas moved me
more than it probably should have like i
think san andreas is a genuinely like
very very good disaster movie he has one
of those qualities of an actor where
like there is no film that he has done
that is not better for him being it
which sci-fi channel original movie
would you consider the greater cinematic
masterpiece
sharknado or big ass spider oh i would
say big r spider for sure
and i don't know what what it is about
them that i keep going back to and
i i really should watch proper films
because i do often find myself on sets
where the director's like have you seen
this movie and i'm like nah
no i've seen bigger spider and i've seen
dragon blade um
and that's it um so like that happens
sometimes and i need to get better
references
[Music]
oh my god it's so thick jesus christ
thick boy
[Music]
ah wow
wow oh yeah
yeah this is one of the ones where you
get to it and you're like
why did someone make this like what at
what point in the
in the like you know there's a testing
process there's tasting things
and they got to this and they're like
it's perfect
leave it stop don't add another thing
take nothing away
this is it yeah they like nailed it yeah
oh yeah
this is definitely reminding me of the
the previous
hottest thing i've ever had which was a
uh
like a you know what i'm gonna i'm gonna
pause and go for the milk
you've eaten something on this level
before
somebody once had a um
i think it was called snake bite venom
jerky
and it was just a sheet of
uh like built-on kind of meat
but just coated the first two layers
[ __ ] me yeah absolutely coated the first
two layers in like
chili flakes and like you ate the
tiniest amount of it
and it just took over your mouth very
similarly to how this
is currently doing yeah i'm going to do
a little test now so i've got some i got
some normal milk and i also got some
almond milk
see if there's a difference and i find
it more or less effective
i'd be curious uh for the findings
much the same pretty ineffective i still
feel everything
so back in the day it was sort of a
trope of ours to talk to guests
about their names being name checked in
rap lyrics and i'm really excited
to dust that off today because harry
potter has to be one of the most
name-checked fictional characters in the
history of hip-hop
so what i want to do is just bounce a
couple bars off of you
maybe you like them maybe you don't like
them maybe you're utterly confused i'm
just curious on how each hits your ear
and this first one is from lupe fiasco
keep them in the air like a swan wing
and imma keep it magic as a harry potter
wand swing
great that's very pleasing it's great i
didn't actually know that there was a
like a history of harry potter turning
up in rap lyrics so that's
very cool this next one is from lil
wayne off working them
[ __ ] on my stick but my name ain't
harry potter
they think i'm very hotter your girls
say the same
harry potters broomstick ones there's a
lot of dick stuff you can do in there
one last one for you this is from
cupcake it's a lovely line off cpr
and anytime my [ __ ] wanna be hairy like
harry potter
becky with the good hair is what you
could call her
i mean that's that's genuinely really
funny so yeah
that's uh yeah that'd be that's that's
my favorite that one's impressive i feel
like there's a there's a real jump
these two i mean sorry i'm just like
openly
on camera now cool um but these two
are just how bad is it gonna be because
i can't i mean
i might and even if these were good can
i taste them now
after having done dabong
well there's only one way to find out
for sure
have you i was gonna ask have you ever
had anyone like call back a few days
later and be like what did you do to me
here's what i i think ends up happening
i think while it's happening
is when it sucks the most for people so
like during the actual interview is kind
of when i see that sort of
what's going on what am i who put me on
this show and i'm stuck here sort of
feeling that i'm getting from people
sometimes
but then i think once people finish it i
feel like they almost feel like a sense
of accomplishment so like when they're
done
i feel like they're kind of like hey all
that stuff that happened before it's all
water under the bridge now they're like
and then the next day when they're not
feeling anything they're like let's do
it again it's a very strange thing
yeah it's it's sort of bonding in that
way i'm actually just gonna before we do
this i'm gonna refill one of my glasses
of milk because i got through a lot of
that on my last one
hey that's the move
[Music]
you're very nice by the way to send milk
thank you for that i did have some but
you're very kind
hey shout out dom yes thank you dom
um all right okay [ __ ] up
[Music]
okay let's start off with this
i don't know what a small one is anymore
this is why i can't drink anymore
all right
i mean impressively
it is cutting through the last one
and replacing that flavor with whatever
new flavor this is
but you're going back in for more i
think i may be with slightly cowardly
then i'm gonna
[Music]
respect
yeah the combination of all of them
is almost like um you know yeah
it produces a slightly stimulant effect
there's like a there's like a nice
little head rush sometimes when you get
that heart fading
that's uh that's enjoyable so i haven't
met many brits who prefer the american
version of football how did a kid from
the uk
become all consumed with playing fantasy
and rooting for the new york giants
it was when i it was when i was doing
the musical because i was doing how to
succeed
and somebody gave me somebody was like i
need i'm making
like i'm doing a fantasy league can i
need numbers like can you just be
like come up with a team i was like okay
fine
and i had no interest in it and then
like
three weeks in i was informed that my
team was oh and three because you know i
hadn't
opened my profile or done anything to it
and i was like well that
sucks i don't wanna be owen three i
don't wanna be at the bottom of the
league so i suppose i'll like take an
interest in that
and then that was just like it became
completely obsessed and
like it's a perfect sport for fantasy
there are so many ways of
quantifying football not just in the
point scoring but also in yards and that
that
like you can build an incredible kind of
game around it but
um nfl and nhl because my girlfriend is
from
uh just outside detroit so she was a big
red wings fan growing up so i those are
my two like adopted sports
okay definitely um still tasting the
last two
oh yeah i can smell this already
yeah i just realized i was uh
i doubt i was dabbing at some more of
the sauce on the plate i
realized i just dabbed a bit more of the
bomb by accident
that was that was an error
classic hot ones mistake but it's one
that you make when you
fully commit to the process of doing a
hot ones
here we are at the curtain call slamming
the door
shut on your episode and saying goodbye
to season 13
and as we say goodbye we'll also be
saying goodbye to some of these sauces
so i want to take this opportunity
last episode of the year to ask you this
daniel radcliffe would you be so kind it
would be an
honor if you could rank the season 13
hot one sauce gauntlet from the sauce
that you like the most
to the sauce that you like the least
okay yes
well obviously like this guy is right at
the bottom no one needs to no one needs
to try that
um i would say
this one also similarly is like
so hot that it's not really nice there
is some flavor there but it's not i
wouldn't like
my mouth has gone entirely numb so if
you just want to experience that that's
very good
but it's uh it's it's not the bomb i
would just not not
do there is no reason for that um
then probably this one again because i
like but then it would be
this is my favorite the go rider that
ended up being my favorite because that
is like barbecuey and intense
with a little bit of that kick but still
very very pleasant
same for both of these i enjoyed both of
them a lot they uh
well i i was that was the one that i was
thought like oh this is going to be
start to get unpleasant here and it's
actually like just the right amount of
fieryness oh yeah that last dab really
hangs around doesn't it
but you know what you handled it you
took it down
the hot one's gauntlet slayed by daniel
radcliffe now there's nothing left to do
but roll out the red carpet for you and
say goodbye to season 13.
this camera that camera probably just
the camera you're looking at
let the people know what you have going
on in your life yeah uh
well personally i'm you know building a
lot of lego because back inside
but if you want to watch stuff with me
um you want to escape from victoria that
is on demand also i did a movie called
uh guns
kimbo that is very very crazy and that's
on demand too i think
i was in the kimmy schmidt movie that
was on netflix this year with ellie
kemper and
lots of amazing other people and uh
written by
tina fey and robert carlock and genuine
and and sam means and meredith
escardino thank god i remembered her
last name um
and uh they they are amazing at what
they
public what they wrote on that show is
still blows my mind so if you want to go
and check that out
that's also cool good job
good job thank you so much for having me
that was very that was also a lovely
interview by the way thank you very much
and you know we'll see how it goes the
next time i go to the toilet
i i may write and complain who knows
[Laughter]
hey what's going on hot ones fans shawn
evans with a very exciting announcement
wrap your heads around this one people
the hot ones 10 pack
it's finally here that's right you've
been asking us for years
and years and years and after a nice
little workaround with a certain sauce
that is kind of tricky with the
distribution
we finally put together the hot ones 10
pack
just in time for the holidays perfect
for the spice lord on your gift list
or if you just want to ruin a family
gathering
the hot ones 10 pack is here for you
heatness.com
heatness.com heatness.com to get your
hands on the hot ones 10 pack
the hot ones 10 pack we finally sort of
did it